hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to let's play shut up
now remember this is only just shuttered
jello so it's not a full game but I've
heard it's a lot like that PlayStation a
fail frame that I've never played before
so that's nothing to do with that so
let's get in the game and see what
happens now oh I actually have no idea
what I'm getting to do because I didn't
play a fatal frame before and I read the
readme file and it says there's an it
there's an it out there that can kill
you very easily don't know what that has
to do with anything um there's also a
slow-mo bar so I I think it said you can
use slow-motion get away from it easier
so whatever it is it's out there and
it's gonna
it's going to try to get me
I hear things
not see things
okay oh hello okay that was weird I
could have sworn that I thought the game
was like broken or something okay there
could be like some notification that
figs arts Avenue besides a sound so
anyway
setting up camera why this takes so much
time setup all right so I guess while
here I guess I'll just talk to you for
you vit how you doing up there you're
doing good
look so fine today gentlemen handsome
ladies so beautiful you know you're all
shine bright shining stars you're all
your own person
da blah blah blah blah motivational crap
blah blah blah oh it's taking a while to
set up a mic with that oh oh wait no
what oh oh I can move to hell but oh oh
I get it
oh oh what done there's like oh it's
like a room but I don't know I can't I
can't this okay something has whap oh
sorry I spent too much time flirting
with the camera I didn't realize that I
was supposed to oh okay by the way my
voice is still kind of gone from
yesterday Friday's livestream so I
arrived at the asylum now
scary better start investigating for my
report
oh I'm just assuming this guy's good
sarcasm about the stuff so I can lean to
the left and right okay so the
atmosphere and the sound is very good
okay okay okay okay okay
no I'm hitting Kay but it no work Oh
what up okay what not okay I have why
but I can turn film grain on and off
let's see feel great on I can't get
through here cuz I hit Kay and it no
work a candle work maybe that means I
need a key like this key
it's an old key I picked it up I'm gonna
triggers key man I'm bad at this game
already
okay so that was that should have been
much easier this could be useful an
orbit Oh class on orbital classed ah oh
hi hi oh oh I used the orbital clasp and
now I'm going in the back take a picture
put your Hank oh it's recording video
okay because apparently my eyes Earl I'm
like walking around with a camera off
here they ah that was scary
Oh ah that was scary that's what I meant
to say then I said a little bit early
cuz I script all my screams I played
through the game once and then I you
know then I remember what all the scares
before
for I remember all the scares are that
ago hi she screamed there and I should
scream there good ha ha ha
that's how I roll that's how I make all
my let's plays so
hmmm this is actually made by on the
same engine the FPS creator engine which
is the one that used to make the
Slenderman Shadow Man 7 we're going on
big vent big fan
no no I refuse what is that oh that what
what happened I missed it
mister mister mister wha what happened
oh my Oh what happened
something happen nothing happened GERD
ordered all the static okay nothing
happened it's just a static what with
all this static I'm just assuming this
guy is very sarcastic about everything
oh you cut my half that's so scary
anybody even know okay who asked much
better
yeah I know it's not that meter yeah all
I don't have to walk around with its
green lighting all the time
turn that off turn that over haha if I
turn this off ah what what that is
really cooll
whoa oh hi
whoa Hey Baby you walk around Wow what I
can't move I gave up what took to hell
with that I'll remember that thing from
my dream
Oh what the hell I can't move Judith
what's with all the static I know it's
all it's all this data kits go host it's
gross goose okay I can sprint really
wobbly I sprayed like this ah nah I was
using night vision I was don't don't
don't don't don't
okay night vision
oh I keep expecting something to pop out
when that happens hello hello hi okay I
don't even know what I'm looking for if
anything it's like a bunch of stuff
blocking that door I think it's probably
important why did I go into an asylum
why did I do that why was that a good
idea okay was this about a slow-mo bar
slo-mo bar was that the it that I was
was a runaway from with you Hales
huh this will help me be calm can be
deadly if I choose the wrong one
what Oh how would I know but I'm not
gonna take any of those I'm totes calm
what can fix up your camera what's wrong
with your camera what's wrong with the
camera what did you do to your frickin
camera an old key a mysterious haunted
touch nothing ah okay I heard footsteps
I don't think I like this game no I
actually like this game it's very very
ha ha ha ha todrick our God our God we
don't want any aah
I'm gonna kill you good way dude
ha ha ha oh I pushed it oh I thought it
was turning towards me ha ha oh you know
so scary
ah good yeah get out of here huh who's
there anybody hello my vit my vision is
going wobbly Oh
a third don't don't it's really dark in
here and it's blinking ah my eyeballs
I shouldn't have fixed up my camera with
that duct tape well maybe that light's
just you know don't do don't turn turn
turn
okay I'm gonna keep this because this is
annoying all right
no no thank you
haha go away old Keene I bet this is
used to unlock that other door can I
pick it up please
there we go okay then I do my wobbly
sprint on over here
yep oh god no he's dead he's dead oh ha
ha I'm loading not a loading cream they
take forever
these loading screens do take a seem to
take quite a while I don't know why that
deserved a loading screen I actually
don't know what the objective and or the
um three days earlier what say what say
what I don't know I better just go
goodbye
a good some slate now uh I'm a rich
famous businessman oh no wait I'm I'm
still use WASD I knew that I was I was
well aware of that information way
before you told me I like to drink while
reading a case oh good that's good for
you
actually a little wine is good good for
you in an awful run take my camera okay
so this is still the cameraman guy antor
to use how about the left click f4
vision you know I I knew all these
things I don't know why I need to know
all them now my car keys da ba Boop I
sneezed and my whole head vibrated
probably a medical condition that I
should look into and turn to you I'm
gonna left click okay if that's okay
with you I don't use it too much just
for the news
this is Welford wharf hash with every
new goodnight okay anyway I go extremely
slow when I'm in my own house apparently
ah now I'm running for different reasons
t4 motion motion motion what do you mean
motion oh is that like a slow motion oh
and now we're back
why did what what why why I figured all
of that out why was that necessary
oh I don't know I don't know I don't
know I don't know these things
then again it is just a demo so it's um
it's not the final product so I'm not
gonna judge anything based on uh I'm
just gonna poke fun at it cuz that's
what I do my sleep wasn't peaceful
though my heart starts to slow down I
have the centum new gotten up shaking
merging by God couldn't read that it was
shaking oh oh seek to cross oh oh this
is good that damn sound waked me up
oh god I lose dreaming I'm in a dream
this isn't real isn't it hmm it's gonna
look good eyepatch I'm [ __ ] today ha
ha no you are you know hi lady
oh hello you're a bug ancient you're not
supposed to be there is you mmm nice
nice and oh you've got like what blades
for arms yeah you're not so scary dot i
okay so moving on from that totally not
scary thing whatever that was supposed
to be I have no idea kliklak aah oh
they're everywhere
uh-huh I can't I don't have night vision
here oh go away oh go away go away go
away go away press shift to run thank
you oh they're everywhere
oh they're floating ha ha ha oh my oh
what's that on my tape uh I don't I
don't even know even know I don't even
know I'm gonna
ah god damn it was not ready for that
God Oh [ __ ] jumpscares
okay so yeah this okay so it's just the
end of the demo
haha by the game creators man good thing
I didn't cut it early I'm thinking about
what does that would have been a bad
idea
what's going on
Kagame's deductions good job with this
man man it's amazing what people have
been able to do by using this FBI later
I have to look into this because I've
you know I've wanted to like take a
crack at like a game and this is like
it's just incredible and I wake up oh so
we're not done yet
oh we're not done oh yeah oh that was
just the intro what what yeah I got
looking at this FPS creator thing
because this is this is really some I
mean I'm really impressed by what you
can do with the abysmal shuttle I guess
that sequence was supposed to be intro
it doesn't need to be that way you don't
need to do it like a flashback style
thing just time to the game creeps it's
great it's good story ah there it is it
is the end okay to be continued that was
the demo so great job guys
I don't make game so I can't give you
any advice really but that was that was
great
that was great everybody the links in
the description below check out the game
totally free right now it may be pay to
play but if it's this good and has a
full game behind it that's good damn
good game like everybody um I got a look
into the FPS greater because this like
this is this is amazing
giving people the tools to do stuff like
this and I don't know how easy or hard
it is I mean obviously to do anything
you need to know some programming and
art skills but that's really cool well
done great great start to a game lots of
potential in that one so on thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotations for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye-bye